well to me it's a tremendous honor I
mean you know it's only been given once
before and that was given to the people
who developed the internet and the world
wide web and computer browsers and I
mean so you know that's a pretty nice
company to be you know to have but
that's what all medical release systems
I mean how important are they well
medical release systems I mean their
whole ranges of them you know and
probably take them all the time some are
pills that last a long time some are
transdermal patches that you put on
we've also we've done a lot with
injectable and implantable systems like
little microspheres that you know you
could put a drug in which normally would
be destroyed right away and it can allow
it to last from why is it important that
the medicine is released over a period
of time well some of these medicines if
you don't release them over a period of
time they're destroyed actually in
seconds so let's say you took a peptide
or a fairly large molecule you actually
can't swallow that you can't put it in a
patch it's too big to go through the
skin if you inject it it's destroyed
immediately so you know you can't inject
yourself every every couple seconds so
so that that's why it's important it
makes that it makes the use of these
practical it also tremendously improves
patient compliance I mean sometimes
they're people who are mentally ill have
diseases like schizophrenia and so
they're some of these treatments you
know they're they help people I mean you
don't have to remember to take them and
you've pioneered the use of materials of
polymers haven't you I mean to what
extent if you worked sometimes in the
face of opposition if you challenge the
status quo and as how has that affected
your work well when I was much younger
you know I started doing some of this
work in the 70s and and then what was
conventional wisdom was that certain
types of substances that were
particularly fairly large couldn't pass
through some of these plastics we and
others were designing any more than say
any of us could walk through a brick
wall and so when we published some
papers actually in nature of British
Journal that you could do this it met
with a lot of skepticism from chemists
and engineers because it didn't seem
like that could happen and that was hard
I my first nine research grants were
turned down and
and at MIT worm professor they you know
the department had who hired me left a
year after he came and a couple the
associate department has decided to give
me some advice you know their advice was
I should start looking for another job
one of the things you vote with you
develop was get a tape to tell us about
gecko well that's interesting and Jeff
carpool was one of my postdocs and now
professor at Harvard and I we want to
mimic with the plastic what happens with
a gecko so you could get a lizard when
it exactly so that you could get very
high at you civilly so that it's kind of
almost this is actually tape that you
could use inside the body to repair or
stick onto slippery organs well that's
correct I mean we're not so again at the
only contrast I'd make is a lot of the
polymer systems that I mentioned are
already very widely used this is still
experimental so you know it's not
something you can go and buy yet but
someday I believe it well and it could
be a whole new kind of medical adhesive
your riot and as we said in our
introduction it's been estimated that
you've managed to help about two billion
people I mean that's an enormous
achievement to what extent does that
motivate you or is it all about the
science for you just fascinated by the
engineering of it or does that motivate
you the idea of helping people well no
the reason I went to medical research
and chemical we you know combining
chemistry and medicine and chemical
engineering in the first place was
because I want to help people i mean i
originally though some of the offers i
got were actually to go in the oil
industry and things like that and I I
wasn't as excited about that I really
wanted to see if I could use my chemical
engineering background to do something
whether it be education or or medicine
or something that would help people I
didn't know exactly what I would do but
the idea that I could use science and
engineering to help people that means a
lot to me now we've had a case today in
Britain about triple DNA using DNA from
three parents of course stem cells again
right in Britain was ahead of the United
States and when you're at the frontiers
is Britain a good place to work because
we're more open perhaps than
even the United States and some well I
think Britain's certainly a good place
to work I know I know quite a few of
these British universities that a number
by students or professors at them and
they've done great so I think I mean I
think both Britain and the United States
are good places to work i mean i think
the biggest issue for both right now is
you know decrease in federal funding
because you really want to support basic
research and engineering and basic
research and science but both britain in
the United States I mean the workers is
terrific and certainly in the areas you
mentioned Britain's done wonderful what
about it I mean do you think it's the
right thing to do what some people call
sort of Frankenstein science and
engineering bringing together three
parents to create one child for example
well I don't I mean I'm not an expert in
that particular area but I don't think
of it that way I mean the way I
understand it as what they're trying to
do is just increase the safety of a
procedure that's already being used I
mean in other words my feeling is from
what i've read is that people when they
get the conventional procedures i cain't
bought to compare DNA from a third
source right right exactly but i think
the intent of doing that is so that
people wouldn't get muscular dystrophy
or diseases like that and again what we
what I I think you'd certainly don't
want to do Frankenstein science but you
do want to you do want healthy children
you do want healthy adults and and so I
think whatever we can do to relieve
suffering I mean I think we do want to
do that and no brown who helped found
this Queen as a surprise felt the
engineering was a bit of a Cinderella in
contrast the pure science do you think
it is now getting the credit it deserves
well I think engine I'd like to see
engineering get more and more credit I
think there's just wonderful engineers
all around the world doing fantastic
things I i think there's also wonderful
scientists around the world doing
fantastic thing so I I I think that what
any society gets us what it celebrates
right as we talk about Nobel Prize
winners now we talk about qet prize yeah
no well that's true but i would say
whether it's nobel prizes or qe2 prize
winners neither of them gets the
attention that athlete or movie star
gets and and and i think all these
things are important to kara's young
people thank you very much indeed
congratulations okay